welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm delighted to be joined by
justin mcguire and dan matthews
who have recently become the co-founders
of dmcd global
before this justin was a founder of his
own recruitment business called
mcg and co that he founded in 2010
and successfully grew that business
across dubai hong kong and singapore
and also previously dan was the founder
of his own recruitment business called
daniel marks
which he also successfully grew in
london europe and america
and actually both of them built
recruitment businesses
that serviced the creative marketing and
advertising sector
but have now joined forces along with
alan smith
adam topton to form dmcg global
absolute pleasure having you on here
guys how are we hello
always welcome good
so justin is joining us from singapore
for context and
and dan is joining us from new york so
morning and evening
so i think the the comparison there is
dan jones with a
big jug of coffee and justin's got a
whiskey was that i think
so where i want to start just on coming
to you first
like in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
hi jim so um i think the characteristics
you need to
succeed in recruitment are really down
to it's an attitude you've got to have
the right attitude to succeed you know
we can teach the skills i often
look for people who are hungry who are
determined who are passionate you know
all those
words thrown in ultimately it's someone
that that really is
a good sales person because it is a
sales job and that someone that's
willing to learn
and is incredibly resilient um i love
that
dan yeah i completely agree um
completely agree
i think relationships are very important
you've got to be a people person
you've got to understand relationships
communication
uh repetition as well um it's doing the
same thing well
again and again not stopping and keep on
going
um you've got to be resilient uh yeah
there's lots of things that do make you
a good recruiter it's hard to box it
into a few words but
um those are the things i would say the
things that stand out to me
okay so what i'm excited to dig in
with you guys is that starting the mcg
global
and talking about your journeys and
taking your career in businesses
international um speaking to you down
around the sort of licensee agreement
that you
now offer um people to join dmcg global
but where i want to start really quickly
justin let me come to you first but from
what i
look and see online right you worked in
recruitment
two years yeah or you started your own
recruitment business
yeah yeah let's talk about that for a
second like what what
what gave you the right or confidence to
start
like what why did you take the plunge
with that little experience because some
people never
take that first step even though they
may have way more experience than that
so what helps you take the plunge
well to put into context i wasn't a
spring chicken i was 30 years old when i
started
there was there was flecks of gray but
i've done i've worked in the industry i
worked in the communications industry
for seven years
and my journey into recruitment was on
the basis that i worked in digital comms
and no one i couldn't find a recruiter
that really understood what i did
so i saw that there was an opportunity
to get into recruitment because no one
really knew what i did
and i i then proved that i could do it
when i was working for someone else
pretty successfully and
then the the financial crisis came
across in in 2008 and i
i lost my job i so i got i was i was i
was a bit stranded and the point at this
point i had accepted a job in dubai so i
i
moved out to another part of the world
the financial crisis came in
uh i ended up doing it long story short
i ended up doing facilities management
recruitment which i knew
nothing about i mean this is a guy that
did proms and advertising
for and then moved into facilities
management it was essentially placing
security guards as well as and toilet
cleaners as far as i was concerned i
knew nothing about it
so step steps out of that and uh and
really thought what have i got to lose
um because i could use my experience
from working in the industry
and my short but sweet successful time
of recruiting in that industry
and i was in a position i was in a a
place like dubai
where there was a massive opportunity
there was um
dubai had been given quite a lot of cash
from abu dhabi
it was starting to grow it went quite
quickly and recover from the financial
crisis
and there was no talent there so it was
it was
it was it was a an unsuccessful journey
when i first moved out to dubai because
the financial crisis happened and then i
ended up being the right guy in the
right place at the right time
because dubai started to grow and i just
thought what have i got to lose let's
let's give this a crack
and it look it was um optimism
uh naivety a bit of stupidity
and uh perhaps a bit of a bit of
usefulness still that was in a 30 year
old
and you started on your own right just
for content yeah yeah yeah that was
right
i mean i had i had a problem starting in
dubai in the sense that
it was great that there wasn't any
talent there but also there genuinely
wasn't anyone there so
i couldn't i could i ended up going back
to the uk
quite a bit just to find talent and
start moving people out there and
actually ended up
doing a split time between the uk and
dubai
um and i had this office in um
well i was living with my girlfriend and
my wife at the time just in dalston
and um it was it was basically above a
lawyers
and people when people used to call me
they'd think that this office was really
busy because the lawyer underneath the
floorboards were so thin and he had such
a loud voice it sounded like i had
someone in the office with me
and my dubai clients thought i was this
big shot recruiter
who had offices in london and dubai and
it was just me on my on my jack jones
he was just coming bouncing backwards
and forwards between the two
but i managed to um you know basically
promote dubai
uh when a lot when people were kind of
losing their jobs still in the financial
crisis so i was bringing out that first
wave of sort of digital talent
to the middle east in in in 2010 that
was then
and uh and i didn't really look back
from then yeah no
that's really interesting and dan i had
this sort of same question for you but
instead what i want to get your thoughts
on
to thinking of what so hearing what
justin just shared there
do you see sort of some of the similar
sort of things happening now with with
covers so from my lens
i've seen so many recruiters start their
own business
yeah because of that question isn't it
it's like what's the worst that can
happen i've been made redundant
or i've been doing this i've been doing
this job now for the last six months
from my from my living room
like why can't i do this myself and sort
of this environment has encouraged it so
what have you because obviously you're
now having conversations with recruiters
about dmcd global etc like
what have you have you found that has
that sort of translated into 2020
um yeah it has i mean my markets have
been the developed markets london
europe america they've always been very
competitive so you've got a bit of an
edge
uh and support network over
your competitors i suppose um what we're
offering is
people the opportunity to sort of run
their own business with our support
um a lot of the people who we had at
daniel marks who were
most people had six seven eight years
experience were kind of running their
own desks autonomously
um when my md moved on last year i
didn't need to replace him because
people
actually were very much a case of
running their own desk and treating it
like a business
so what we've done here this license
agreement is pretty much
to take that to the next level and say
look you are now literally running your
own business this is your business you
can then ultimately sell
so you're responsible for yourself
you're autonomous but you have all of
our support operations finance
marketing products platforms services
and they take like 70 80 percent of the
line share of what they make
so it's kind of a mix between taking a
step on your own
so it's doing it on your own but doing
it with our support so it's a nice
middle ground for people that
do want to run their own business have
the autonomy flexible working unlimited
holidays and
working under around their own schedule
but not be completely isolated on their
own because as justin said it's not
not nice being on your own i worked on
my own uh for a couple of years when i
set up daniel marks in my living room
with a couple of mates in putney
and it was pretty pretty lonely there's
no one signals here to chew
no one to share successes no one to
collaborate with and it's probably one
of the hardest things about
setting up your own business is that you
are on your own um
and that can be quite soul-destroying um
and actually quite demotivating to a
degree so having a support network and
people around to help
is actually one of the things i think
helps our licenses our licensees our
businesses to
to really grow and expand with the
support and the collaboration
and okay really having other people to
we've got a
zoom chat i've got a webinar later with
like 25 30 people
uh zoom chat on friday but everyone's
going to get together and just chew the
fat
uh and having other people to suffer to
the age with the work with
okay so okay cool so we're we're
definitely going to dig into that so i
guess
let's just go into this then so justin
like why
why let's just talk a bit about like why
you guys have joined forces
right because there's a couple of you
that obviously have have formed the mcg
global so
hit us with the the why have you decided
to do that
okay so it the the obvious one is that
we recruit in
the same sectors so yeah if you were to
you know
there was a a marriage in the sense that
we shared the same clients we
shared the same skill sets uh excitement
about the industry
et cetera dan and i um
actually probably the first bit is dan
and i know and trust each other we've
known each other since we were kids
so after our house erin's were friends
so that's yeah that's a that's a massive
box ticked
we work in the same sectors and we both
tried and and essentially well i can
certainly for myself and failed in
elements of trying to scale our business
as well and it's not very it's you know
it is very difficult trying to take it
it was even different
it was very difficult having a business
in dubai and opening up in hong kong
and singapore and that and then i tried
to move the business and open up in
london and i had a real tough time doing
that and i and i
i pulled back and shut that office after
a year so i had an experience of trying
trialing europe and realized it you know
i couldn't do that on my own
and dan was interested as well in coming
into the middle east and asia
and again he was pretty stretched
because he was opening up in the us and
europe as well
so it made sense for us to pull our
resources together
particularly after we'd both given or
experimented in expanding into the
markets that we reach in as well
that makes sense so dan what
from your perspective then so justin has
given us why like what would you say has
been the most positive impact
so far since joining forces because
this if you were to talk about this
maybe 5-10 years ago how many
recruitment business owners would you
hear talking about collaborating and
actually forming another business with
competitors not sure right so like
what what's been the most positive
impact so far from your perspective
there's been so many positive impacts
actually um like i'm adjusting for a
matter of
30 years or something uh our parents
know each other very well i think i was
actually working in sydney at the time
when justin was launching
now actually i was i'd already done that
i was back in london and running daniel
martin i heard that justin was
doing what he was doing in dubai that's
great i should catch up with him and i
was in dubai every now and then
uh caught up with him and we said look
when we start to do things together
i've gone west you're going you've gone
east it makes sense to collaborate
um what's been really good is having a
global unity so we've got shared clients
which we can share globally
um shared resources uh on certain things
from products and services
uh even even certain hires we've made in
marketing we can share resources on that
um having someone to talk to um you know
in fact we did anyway
she did speak quite regularly just about
the the trials and tribulations of
running a business
um but it's having a community a wider
community so we've got
our patch of london europe and usa but
having colleagues and co-workers
in other parts of the world is really
quite energizing um you know the sun
never sets on dmcg globe but it sounds a
bit cheesy but it's kind of true
so i've got messages coming in we've
just appointed someone for sydney
which is a jv between myself justin and
alan
so this person's starting in a couple of
weeks and you know
like like myself justin's always working
we just kind of enjoy it it's kind of
our life
work hybrid um so having something going
on all the time i really enjoy
um in the morning uk stuff in the
evening it's asia
uh but i think the collaboration piece
the uh have someone else to talk to
someone else to bounce ideas or someone
has to implement
ideas and obviously shared costs allow
us to operate this on scale
yeah so go on justin yeah
well i know i was just gonna say the the
other thing is
let's put covert to one side but we live
in a connected society in a connected
world and actually
the flow of talent what we were finding
was that it's
you know in singapore or dubai i could
have then someone on site and on the
ground in london
if we wanted to relocate someone could
go meet candidates or go and meet
clients or can go
global that was a real unique selling
point for us as well and something that
a real added value that we could offer
people um and the other
nice thing for dan i guess is that i was
in asia when i i knew this coveted
tsunami was coming
and i was i was like the warning system
you know i could i could i could
tell then that there was you know be
prepared buckle up this bad boy is
coming in
more hires weren't we you know yeah
london
and you're like i think we should put
the brakes on yeah
yeah you're like no no seriously this
this thing is coming
um so for me to be probably more
reactive
uh and realize how big this thing was
hitting us was back in march
having had that insight from justin so
thank you mate
yeah so this is the i actually i think
that's so unique and i absolutely love
that so
look justin let me ask you this then so
not just um youtube but also the other
chap involved like you've gone from
being a business owner you make your own
decisions and being only responsible for
your own decisions that's a big reason
why people start their own business to
have
that freedom of decision choice right
so positive is great but how have you
managed now to
that you can't just be like right wake
up justin just gonna decide to do this
there's other people involved now right
how have you how has that been how's
how's that been well i think it helps
the fact that we we
knew each other so we're down tonight
we've we've never really come
to any sort of blows on anything and
you've just got to accept if you're
going to
merge you know parts of the business
together or
you know build something new together
then you're gonna have to compromise and
you're just gonna have you can't
go and do whatever you want and you're
gonna have to listen to other people's
thoughts and opinions
and what i what you also learn as a
business owner is
particularly after 10 years is that
you're not necessarily right all the
time and that is quite important
other people's opinions as well and you
should listen to them um
and and with alan who joined us in
australia well adam
and adam my my business partner at mcg
beforehand
we obviously knew each other and adam
and i worked very closely so
i i already had someone to bounce off
with then
with adam and then i'd met alan about
two years before
we actually ended up doing this as well
firstly he was referred to me by
a client in dubai saying oh you've got
to meet this guy in
australia he does the same thing as you
so when we met him
it was like meeting an aussie justin and
dan
right so it was a very easy stitching
and he was interested in growing but
also
was a bit you know put off by the or
daunted by the fact that
going into another country was a big
step for him and he'd already been
burned
setting up a business in perth and then
moving it to brisbane so he'd
like uh like me certainly and and and
like dan's degree he'd had
you know he'd experience the good and
the bad of trying to expand a business
so
he was brought in we were looking for jv
in sydney me and justin and we were
inquiring about
uh an acquisition or just hiring a good
heads down there and then when alan came
into the picture
um it seemed like a natural uh thing to
join that part of the puzzle together to
have someone on the ground in australia
because again
we're both so stretched on timing like
my days are very long as are justin's
dealing with dubai in the morning
so having someone on the ground and
someone who's got reputation a footprint
a business a great reputation um it made
sense to
us all combined together uh and now
we're pressing head with sydney um
it's all sort of the cogs are clicking
into place
yeah so it seems like if i'm listening
right now and i'm thinking about
joint ventures that the main recipe that
you have to have
is trust um yeah clearly right so
so really quickly dan i so i just want
to ask you this just and then
i'd really appreciate if you just really
just spell out the licensee
agreement that you guys have put
together i know justin you're trying to
formulate the best way to
replicate this also in other areas
but the commercials right so just make
this really clear so i'm a recruitment
business owner listen this or future
recruitment business owner joint venture
sounds great more people involved global
footprint
but how do you actually structure this
then so is it the
yeah so that than the london business
that you you were in that business but
then other people were directors have a
partnership with that business like how
how do the actual commercials work yeah
that's a good question um
a licensee would have their patch and
their specialism so
it could be someone that specializes in
web development
or cyber security or planning and
strategy so
their license would be for that
particular type of
sector um and it's done by territory as
well so some people are uk
some people usa some uh like natasha's
amsterdam
all right sorry right is this the
licensee yeah yeah the license plate
but just quickly you know as a
recruitment business owner so like
dan matthews justin like how have you
structured it in terms of the actual
they actually
just quickly on that i think people will
be interested in how you've done that
because it's
someone who specializes like the same
web developers and that's their thing
they set up their own business which we
assist them with this limited business
it could be called
uh i am limited that i am limited has a
license agreement with dmcg global
and that's what the agreement provides
we is actually very weighted in their
favor
um as a partnership so we we are sure
we're going to give them everything that
they need to be successful is it's even
like training development
sources some of your products services
operations that they get all of those
things included
and they will then operate as their own
business
as a licensee it came to a franchise
really um
there's no sort of i suppose financial
commitment to either party
um so if it's not working that's
absolutely fine and we've chained in
we're we want to work with partners that
are commercial want to make this work
um does that make sense does that
clarify how it works yeah yeah sorry
i think the the real what i was what i
was trying to the reason why i cut you
off there dan so that's the licensee
right i guess what
the question was so if this isn't clear
was basically
i was interested in if i if i was in the
position of you
and daniel marks how have you structured
it
where i don't know how you structured it
from a you i go from daniel mark's being
the so owner of that business
now being um a co-founder of the mcg
global
commercially how have you structured
that with justin with alan with adam
that's what was interesting because i
think people would be interested in that
how do you
look at my patch which is uk europe and
usa so i'm i can point licensees in
those territories
and licensees would then have their own
business which is
has the uh license agreement which they
can then develop and grow and then
ultimately sell and it's always to keep
it when they sell it and someone else
might take that license on
it's actually easier to sell a license
agreement than selling a business
because you might be a one or two man
shop
um so that that's how it works and
people have a patch a territory
and an and a specialism that could be
planning a strategy it could be
uh like i say it could be a niche of
cyber security we don't want to be
limiting
people but they're basically got the air
that they think they would they would
work on
if it's an air which is not untouched no
one's working they can obviously go with
it but
no one's got a license that's restricted
beyond like they
it's not they can't do things they'd
want to do so it's their specialism but
this
is we've actually pointed the person
recently who's dealing with the sales
side of things
so no we're dealing with national sales
advisors sales directors sales managers
so
it doesn't it doesn't encroach anyone
else's patch
we're looking at bringing someone next
year to do accounting and finance for
all our clients with all the media
agency consultancy clients
someone's to focus on the accounting and
finance side of things so
it's we're going to stick to our core
but then you can raise it out from that
yeah sure and then just because
obviously recruiters want to know this
so
if i was to become a licensee within the
mcu global
so you've explained sort of yeah the
what you'd support them with
um and how it would work but like so if
i
how does it work with earnings then
because i know you made this quite
simple when we spoke
if they make a placement and say the fee
is 20 grand
um they would get between 14 and 16
grand of that
so we take care of all the invoicing we
just process all that we've got two
people that specialize in just invoice
chasing so we'll raise the invoice get
the money and
we pay that person within five days so
we basically
if they make a placement we collect the
money and just pay them straight away
and we pay them as their own
limited business so if it was i am
limited we would pay i unlimited and
that person can then pay themselves how
they want to they can pay themselves
a salary they can pay themselves in
dividends uh they can
you know buy tech and stuff as tax
deductible it's running their own
business potentially
and we've got financial sort of forecast
for them they can work out how they're
gonna
manage it but it's essentially running
your own business and we we we support
that
nice and then justin for you then what's
been the journey so far in trying to
replicate that
in your part of the world yeah it's um
so we have in singapore dubai and hong
kong we've got
expats quite a few expats in our
business and there's quite a few
legal so we say loopholes to jump
through to get an expat to
set up an independent business that
franchises into
a holding group so we've got to run a
bit of a hybrid model there so for local
it's um we can we can do this plug-in
and play
um design and structure the dance just
run through but for expats
for quite a few of them particularly in
hong kong and singapore you need to
you need to basically have a salary to
work here and
that doesn't obviously having your own
business then and plugging in a
franchise model doesn't work very well
so we have to
we just have to adopt to the rules that
there are in in the different
territories that we have
um so for locals we can run it for
expats we
we we run a more typical kind of
recruitment salary in commission
structure
but from talking to people um
the bit that everyone loves you know is
is the big bit about it is our brand
right so we
dab both dan and myself alan adam the
four um
partners we've really invested a heck of
a lot into our brand we've got you know
on social media we've got nearly half a
million followers
we've got invested into marketing we've
we do branding courses we've you know we
really make a point of
showcasing who we are so we naturally
have a lot of a lot of candidates a lot
of clients
and people can just plug into that and
so the benefit of them not doing
themselves is obviously that
they can they can we can do all the
groundwork for them they can feed off
our brand
but then they can earn quite a
significant chunk of their earnings
yeah my i might daniel mark's website
was great it was it looked good
but what we've got now is completely
different beast it's it's built from the
back end by recruitment specialists
we've got
marketing the specialists in digital
marketing and
all the products and the platforms and
services that uh oh you know even
even a large or mid-sized recruitment
company we wouldn't be able to have the
capacity to accommodate having all of
those
functions and services and products and
platforms but we can do that on scale
and
every licensee gets to benefit from
having that at their disposal
from linkedin recruits the license but
all the type of marketing stuff that
goes with that yeah
so definitely keen to dig into sort of
the conversation you've been having done
with people around this but
i guess also justin feels to jump in
here but dan so
i think as a recruitment business owner
if i'm listening to this right now
sounds great mitigate the risk i'm not
paying people salaries i may not even
have to pay an office
all these types of things right but you
actually
um obviously put people on this
agreement or communicate this agreement
to people
that you had on a salary right so let's
let's just talk about that for a like
how because i'm i might think you know
what
dan and justin is really innovative this
is actually something that i might think
about for my own
for my own business how did that
how was that received old people they
were like thinking okay how's this going
to work and i've taught them through it
and
there's an element of trust i've known a
lot of the people who were with me at
daniel marks for
seven eight nine years um i think they
trust me that you know i know what i'm
talking about
um and it was a step of faith initially
um but everyone every single person that
came over
is still with us uh and then we've
actually taken on maybe another
nine ten licensees in the last month
uh and no one's left everyone's joined
and they're actually enjoying it i said
the other day i said you know when the
when as soon as the placement happens
and it's starting to happen quite
quickly now
um do you want to go back to the old
model and then i'll just get a laugh
back he's like why would i come back
to getting like i know 15 20 25 30 even
40
because the salaries as much as it is
it's nowhere near like if people are
building 200 250 300k
they're now taking home 180k 200k
and i worked it out and everybody was
making double sometimes
three times as much as what they were
making when they're on the salary with
the commission
um because it's just a better model for
that and if you're good at what you do
and you're self-motivated um why would
you want to
give everything to someone else and if
you do leave you leave all of that
behind whereas this is something you can
then build up and
when you leave you can then sell it um
it just makes a lot of sense i think
you know the people that are doing it
are now seeing the benefits of it
and wouldn't want to go i don't think
anyone's going to want to go back to a
salary after this but why would you if
you're taking home you know
70 80 of what you're making um it's a
huge amount
um and it makes a real difference yeah
so
initially oh my god what the hell i'm
not gonna have a salary to write okay
let's actually understand
last year i build this if i build that
this year but this is how much i'd make
yeah okay well one place when i say 20k
you get 14 16 grand
that's that's quite a lot of money and
you have you know we had some people in
the first three weeks that were making
placements and
one chat made 45 grand in the first
month so he took home 30 grand
in in the first month that he wouldn't
have got anything like that he'd have
made me make five
um
but it's we do have like docking i've
got hubs everywhere we've got hubba new
york i have in london
it's a place where people can go and we
collaborate work it's open like 9
30 to 6 and then it's like a jazz bar uh
so hope like so after that there's like
a place for people to go
to collaborate to work to meet clients
we can provide all those things for
people to do that so there really are
it is like working in a recruitment
business
but you just got more responsibility and
more more rewards
okay so on this sort of part of
communication justin
um we always talk about this in podcast
whenever i talk to recruitment business
owners about their journey and things
like that
a lot of the advice that they give or
share is around
the importance of defining the purpose
of your business
and then why you do what you do and
being clear on your values so also i
um i think obviously maybe you guys had
slightly different values for mtg and
cohen and daniel mark so i guess
from your point of view adjusting
communicating to your teams right i know
it's not
straight away segueing into the licensee
agreement as you explained
yeah like how did you approach sort of
communicating the purpose of this
sort of collaboration right because that
would have been important that that went
right and how important was defining
the purpose of the mcg global yeah i
think
so we've uh the foundation that the
business was was set up and was was
basically if you go back to that story i
told you
why i got into recruitment it's because
i came from industry and realized
that people didn't really know what i
did so it was always around
integrity and being specialists in our
field and we've always fed off the back
of that
and so i have a really good you know
bunch
of specialists who understand
our sector but they all they most of
them as i said is quite an expat heavy
business that i've got
um most of them aren't from the country
that they actually work in and probably
that's probably the big difference
between what what i've
encountered with dan and so
there isn't that security blanket if all
else fails you can go and live at mums
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
before if
you need a visa to be there and you need
medical insurance or something bad
happens so
it's having some of those conversations
some people are
you know open to it others are a little
uneasy because it's just there isn't
the legal framework that can support
them um so we
we're looking at building this in
building a model like what dan's got
into
singapore dubai and hong kong but we
have to it works as a city before it
works really well for the locals
so for the singaporeans yeah yeah that
makes sense
and and in dubai actually there
basically isn't any emiratis that work
in
recruitment in fact i have never met one
that worked in marketing and advertising
uh they tend to sign the checks not do
most of the work
they're the guys that sit the top so we
we essentially need to help wouldn't
the way it it's it's looking like we
need to do it in device we need to help
them set up their own separate business
that then plugs in i'm not going to get
down to the complications
it's a lot it's a lot more difficult so
the conversation i've had with everyone
is yeah
most people are up for it but they want
to know that they're going to be
safe you know that their families
because we as a business we also
you know we have a responsibility to
people if they've got families as well
um because if they you know if they're
the main breadwinner we've got to make
sure they're all right so
it's just those little nuances that
we've got to try and help them and and
shape with
um in an expat society
and just on that so yeah completely
understand that i guess it was
just more of like if you had people that
have been with you for a long time
just you know going hey guys look so
we're now actually going to become dmcd
globe and they're going to hang on a
minute we've we've worked hard to build
the
cg encode brand i guess i was just
interested in how that landed and
okay people listening to this might be
thinking about jv's and stuff like that
but worried about how that might be
received
internally right it was um there was not
a single person that didn't understand
why we were doing it and and
we we made a point of talking about this
from the outset so i think one of the
things i've learned in business and as a
leader is always just to be
treat your employees don't hide stuff
from them treat them as adults
you know just be straight with them and
so when i started having these
conversations with dan
i pretty much was quite open and honest
with everyone about where we were going
what the vision and mission
on that journey yeah yeah yeah i've
always been very open
uh i think i you know i'm the sort of
person that
has always been like that throughout my
life i i like to keep people
communicated i don't mind showing a bit
of vulnerability when things are bad i
don't mind
um explaining to people what i want to
do how we want to grow it
people had seen our success people had
seen particularly like the long-term
members of staff they'd seen we'd given
london to go and necessarily
go according to plan um and what we'd
learned from that and
most people could see that that made a
lot of sense yeah
okay so and just a quick one so dan
with um daniel marks how many how many
people who ended up working in the new
york function
just out there in march we had uh well
in
february we had what seven people in the
new york office
24 in london um and a couple
in amsterdam yeah what i wanted to ask
yeah model basically apart from just a
couple of people in london
what i wanted to ask was and then justin
and be keen to get your thoughts on this
from a business owner perspective and
keen to go on a recruit
recruitment consultant's perspective but
i think from the conversations that i've
had on this podcast and
and also just from a business
perspective
um this year has sort of highlighted
for some businesses how valuable it has
been for them to diversify
their roommate business if that's making
sure they don't have free key accounts
that
give them x amount of revenue or if
that's not been relying
on one country for their revenue right
so i think
from the conversations that i've been
having there'll be a lot of recruitment
businesses thinking about
internationalization
and diversifying their business i think
um 2019
most ambitious progressive recruitment
businesses i spoke to
would have america on their business
plan as
an area they want to grow the fees are
bigger um and
the the competition is less and the few
other sort of key things that always
jump out
but like justin said earlier when he
tried to get start london and it failed
a lot of recruitment businesses do fail
right in taking their businesses
internationally so i guess
what's been your learning on that that
you can share with uh recruitment
business owners that listen to this
that what do you think are sort of the
the three most important things in
giving yourself the best possible chance
of
growing your recruitment business
internationally that you've learned down
oh it's it's very point you've got like
a lot of time and resource for this
it wasn't the case of right let's have a
new york office overnight
it took about a year and a half of
paperwork filings ultimately was 185
page document
um and 100 investment to actually start
getting this thing moving
um i'm on an e2 as is the company um
which is good to get it's five years and
i can extend it
uh but it was it's it takes a lot of
time it takes a lot
a lot of legal um uh yeah
time resource and putting a proper plan
together
a proper business plan me coming over to
to leave it really help because i was
here on the ground and i still am in new
york now
um london's great and it's got such a
really strong team of people
and i was last year i was back to london
seven times uh
i moved to new york permanently last
january
about two years ago now but i was back
and forth before that but last year i
was back in uk seven times
every six week a week uh this year
obviously i've been able to leave new
york state
for a year um which is very different
that
um yeah being here on the ground like
justin found he was in dubai when he
moved to singapore
it you know he can really start to grow
it so having a presence here
for me to actually be hands-on and to
help grow it really help but
i didn't want to leave london alone
obviously it's been
it's my it's the core of the company so
i'm that's why i'm up at
5 6 every morning because the uk's
already five hours ahead of me so
it's uk is a really strong part of our
business and the us is
another part of the business that i'm
here on the ground and growing um and
we've got merit on the on the west coast
and growing the
the la and then san francisco office but
like i said my time was so split
uh time money resource all of these
things which is why i was
you know really thinking would be good
to collaborate on asia so i was looking
at an office in dubai in an office in
in singapore hong kong and i started
getting processes underway
then it's another country to do
accounting on another country to all the
legal zones
there's so much so many so much time and
resource into it that
i'm i've gone west you've gone east
justin we can collaborate on this and
we've got the whole world covered
justin what about you what's been your
journey with this and taking
while you were talking i was just
thinking god what was i thinking because
not only did i set up a business
after only two years in recruitment but
i actually set one up in a country i'd
really never
been to before um it was you know it was
it was it was a bit off the cuff kind of
wow um no it was basically i i was in
dubai
and it was getting it was going great
for five years and
we were we were really i thought i could
i could do no wrong i thought i could
everything i was doing was touch the
gold so my natural movement i felt was
where's the other expat place that a lot
of people like going my side of the
world and hong kong was the first one i
could think of so we were
inevitably when it was when we were
looking to bring an expat talent into
dubai we were competing with
hong kong and singapore so those that
sort of triangle if you will was always
my idea of where we wanted to build the
business and my thinking for london was
well
we take a lot of talent out london so
why don't we try and put something there
and
that make that sort of the four hubs but
um
once once we realized that london wasn't
right for us we really sort of doubled
down and focused on
hong kong and singapore and actually you
know what because i'd already built
business in the emerging world
let's call it the emerging world um it
there were sort of nuances and
complications that setting up in dubai
that were quite similar in hong kong
and were quite similar in singapore as
well you know there's a lot of red tape
if you're an expat business you've got
put quite a bit of investment in
you've got to prove that you've been a
successful business for two three years
at least you've got to have clients
really that you know you can work with
or you can bring with you otherwise it's
an enormous amount of
money but the hardest thing the hardest
thing and
again this goes down to the biggest
irony in recruiting isn't it that
it's finding the right people and i you
know i always
you have to kiss a few frogs sometimes
you know what i mean it's um
it's it's hard to find people that you
can trust to run a business thousands of
miles away
um and that i think that was the the
hardest bit was taking
the dna you had in your business and
teleporting that to somewhere thousands
of miles away
and also trusting someone to build and
set up business with the same passion
that you had
when you had in dubai so you've got to
find partners you've got to get them to
be business owners you've got to
you know trust them to do it in a
foreign land because um
we had you know we had a mixture of
expats and locals but most of the
leadership we had when we first go were
expats so
it was a real there was lots to learn
from it and as of most things i found in
business
you got to fail before you succeed yeah
i love that no
some really interesting points here so i
guess a core mission statement core
values
things that everyone knows um in fact in
daniel marks we had
obviously mission statement of values as
well um we've got new mission statement
values for dmcg global but
they overlap a lot in in having the type
of individuals who are
who are collaborative communicative um
they like to um i suppose
they're commercial um but the slight
difference more on dmc global is more
entrepreneurial side of things um but
having those mission statements and
values that everyone knows
no one got promoted to daily marks
without living those values more so than
the billing side of things
and although this new this new model um
the values are very much the same
but adding in that layer of extra layer
of autonomy and an extra layer of
commercialism an extra layer of
entrepreneurism
yeah so i guess what i wanted to touch
on there so you're talking about from
business owner perspective some great
insights there
justin but down from your experience
then if i'm a recruiter listening to
this and
um i want to become an expat in a
country that i might spend some time in
may not spend some time in like from
your experience from speaking to
recruiters
about going over to america or or
wherever amsterdam
like what do recruiters typically
wrongly assume when taking their career
out of the country that they grew up in
typically let's say
the uk like where wherever you sort of
typically found that recruiters
maybe didn't think about i mean a few
things that have come up on this podcast
is around
that that's great you could earn more
money in america but actually
don't forget the personal side then you
have to put yourself out there if you
don't
make friends you don't try and make
social circles you're going to be really
lonely
and that could impact your time spent or
end up
yeah cutting your journey long short so
i guess from your experience if i'm
listening to this right now and i
genuinely love the opportunity or think
about the opportunity of taking my
career internationally
what should i definitely be sort of
understanding about that move
i think you have to be wary of the fact
that people have like i've
mentioned before about having
professional equity you've earned it
you've got
clients you've got candidates you've got
people who you know and trust and they
trust you and you can take that wherever
you go
when you relocate somewhere you lose a
little bit of that actually because you
you don't have those people
who used to work within your territory
anymore uh we
learned a lot of shared clients shared
types of roles but
you you lose a little bit your candidate
based on your client base it's a little
bit of a reboot
from doing your market you have to sort
of scale it and grow again your
reputation
uh your relationship so that's a bit of
a reset um
being in new york the biggest people i
found is just it is such a hectic place
it's so
caffeinated and commercial we've had
like we had a present here for a year
and a half
like year before last after year and a
half of being in manhattan he wants
to go back to london back to the uk it
was so so noisy
uh it's so hectic um it's quite
expensive
and it's that sort of culture shock i
suppose that people want to do it and
then after a year or so i think actually
i kind of done it now i want to go back
which is a shame for us because it's
such a great place to be but it's not
for everybody
i'm sure justin will find that as well
when people go to hong kong or suddenly
it is a busy city what have you found
justin and
and sort of going through this journey
with people yeah
i've found that particularly in the
areas that i've set businesses up and
that
it's just not easy at all right for a
start there's
setting up businesses in in the
locations that i have there's quite a
significant amount of investment and red
tape that goes into it
then once you've got the people there
and you start hiring people
particularly if you're going to bring in
expats from the uk over to say
singapore hong kong or dubai the biggest
thing you've got to remember is that
they might not have any network
whatsoever in that location so not only
do you bring them over
but you're you're not only are you their
boss but you're also there
kind of dad or they're friends
and i feel really sorry for everyone
having imagine having me for a dad
and a boss wow um but you know you are
taking a big responsibility there
because you're looking off people's
medical you're moving them away from
their home
you have to help them you know you
inevitably help them out with their
housing or their moving
elements that are involved there it's
opening up bank accounts
all that all the all the necessary
things that they need to do you you
basically have to go
give people an induction to the country
and then if they haven't got any friends
their
your social world and your work world
combine
you know completely together so you end
up socializing and working with people
and it's quite an intense relationship
you have with them
and you form very close friendships and
very close bonds or
you know if people don't get along you
know sparks can fly quite quickly as
well so you've got a
it's it's it's a real tough thing
bringing people out from their their
their home country into such a
you know a foreign land and let me just
talk about some of the areas that we
recruit him because
you know japan for example i mean take
everything you learn in the uk
and put it in japan and it's like you
know it's like landing on mars
okay it's it's it's
the way they work the the cultures the
processes the how you find people
there's barely anyone on linkedin you
know it's it's a very
different way of working so it's you
know i remember i'll never forget it
when i had a guy training
on you people that came to dubai and the
first thing you used to say to them was
everything you've learned in the uk i'm
just going to tell you now
beyond the basics you need to forget it
because this is a whole new world
and it is because you're talking to most
of our clients in dubai had
35 different nationalities in them their
offices so imagine if you're talking to
people from all those different
countries all you know
the the way you interact with them the
way you handle them the way
you might think they're being rude you
know when they actually that's just the
way they go about
talking you know you've got to learn all
those things and it's a blank canvas
it's a real
tough thing to learn so take can take
people three to six months just to
understand the cultural nuances
i think what i'd say sorry i've done it
at least for a year
um right away but off the bat it's quite
a lot of resource needed for that
and it is it is uh you know new york's a
great place it's very
you know it's this is one wonderful city
but it is very lonely if you don't know
anyone
so when we brought people over it is a
case like justin saying
um you've been on social calendar taking
the places and
let them find their feet but there's
more that we're doing we can't really
bring people over on visas because
they're not being sponsored so we're
always looking for local talent we have
a local market already
and then we support them in that basis
yeah sure i think what i take from that
is yeah if i'm if i'm looking to take my
recruitment career internationally on i
need to meet more than just the per
manager that i'm going to work for and
things like that because that's going to
be a big
impact on people that i might end up
spending a lot of time with uh yeah
requirements of not just yeah being in
the office with them but actually they
could
they they could likely form your first
social circle right which
that could make things a lot easier at
the start
yeah you and and even you know i didn't
my i got offered a job in dubai time the
financial crisis and i could see you
know
my office wasn't far from lehman
brothers i could see people you know
leaving their offices with boxes in
their hands i was like
this isn't the right place to be right
now so when i got that job offer in
dubai i went there
but i'd never actually been to the
middle east you know i didn't even have
the chance to give it a recce
and i wouldn't recommend people do that
because
it really was you know going into
something blind quite literally and
so if you get the opportunity to go out
there think about where you want to live
if you've got some mates from school i
felt i was i was amazed by how many
people actually knew from my periphery
social circle that were out there as
well and people tend to be very friendly
in expat locations you know
if you've just dropped an email saying
hey i know jeff jeff said that i should
meet you for a drink
inevitably that person will go and meet
you as well
yeah because i guess a lot of people a
lot of people being in their shoes right
and know what it can be
like and feel like at the early days so
what i wanted to
um ask you dan and also can come to you
justin but when i look at the the people
that
worked for um daniel marks a lot of the
if you look at the average tenure
it's a long time right um
so we always so you always hear
recruitment companies talking about the
challenge of hiring a new
new new talent but what would you say
have been the sort of
free core pin principles for you that
has really enabled you to retain
your talent actually keep hold of some
of your best staff which i think
a lot of the time doesn't get focused on
as much right so what do you think
you've done or advice for people
listening to this that
um has really helped you retain your
best people well i'd have to say it just
comes down to being
good recruitment it's like a plumber
with a leaky tap
we're not a plumber with a leaky tap we
we are people
our clients and we recruit for ourselves
so
we just make sure we hire really really
good people and it's not like it's a
massively lengthy interview process
it's announced that justin would have as
well from spotting good people quite
quickly
we're taking on new licensees maybe one
to a week at the moment
and a lot of people we could be going
with and it's how it's
how they interact a lot of these chats
now these meetings i'm having are on the
zoom
it doesn't matter you can still pick up
a vibe very quickly
um so so it's a figures are there
obviously you've got figures have got to
be good
uh we've had people have had good
tenures at places before
we don't people have had like a year
year year year everyone has hiccups
everyone moves for different reasons
especially at the moment
but generally if you're a good recruiter
i wouldn't suggest you move jobs every
nine months for five years
there's normally a reason why so it's
being smart about who you're hiring
it's been quite transparent and honest
at the start about what what the
opportunity is and how it's going to
work
and then providing a supportive
collaborative environment
where we look after people and everyone
feels genuinely part of a team
and supported um and i'm here to support
everybody as well
i'm always available everyone knows that
so it's just making the right hires
and you know looking after people um and
doing what you say you're gonna do and
being honest and quite transparent and
being trustworthy
the same things that justin was saying
earlier actually
justin what what's helped you retain
some of your best after you think
that you've done well or that you've
noticed has had an
impact on retention uh it's attitude
you know it goes back to that sort of
first question you asked me what's the
the traits that i find in a best tracer
final recruiter it's
that willingness to succeed you know i
know that sounds really cheesy and corny
but
when i first set up i really had not a
lot of money yeah like most business
owners beginning of their journey so i
had to put put together and i know the
guys
um with me at the beginning of that
journey won't mind me calling them that
but
a riff-raff pack of people that
didn't necessarily bit like me we hadn't
necessarily got the
the longest recruit or well a great deal
of experience in recruitment but had
that passion and willingness
and you know stupidity should we say
to succeed and i had a team at one point
there was a guy
when i met him he didn't speak english
uh i had to teach him english as well as
recruitment um and he ended up being our
top top
salesperson for two years or top miller
for two years which is a brilliant story
there was someone that i knew again i
knew his mum and
i thought well i know his mum he's a
he's a good egg i'll give him a go yeah
you know he became a loyal guy there was
another bloke
actually he works for dan um who
came fresh out of uni uh he met one of
my guys whilst traveling here in
thailand i got a bit of luck with him
so i put together this this group of
people that were if you look at it the
commentary was they were really they had
this
real hunger and desire to succeed and
win i took you know there was a couple
of stories where i took failed
recruiters and turned them into really
successful ones because when they landed
in say dubai or singapore or hong kong
and they saw the opportunity in front of
them compared to uber competitive low
lower margin really hard business in
london
they took they they took it with open
arms and they milked it and they worked
really hard and they became super
successful really quickly
and that was the seemed to be the trait
that that ran through everything
um what what makes it quite tough um not
necessarily you've got
well if you've got locals in singapore
and hong kong you'll find that
um they get approached quite a lot by
other recruiters because lots there
isn't many great recruiters who are
saying
hong kong or singapore nationals yeah
respect because it's just quite a new
industry and in dubai it's really an
expat market so you you
you know you the one of the frustrations
you can have is you can have someone
that you're having a great relationship
with is doing brilliantly
and unfortunately for personal reasons
they might have to leave the country
or yeah they might um be sick or have to
have another job opportunity and they
they then leave so
you know it that can be a real sort of
um kick as well when you train someone
i've had a great relationship with them
they've been a success and you want to
build something around them and then
they just have to leave for the
situations that were really out of your
control
yeah um when we uh i sat down master
2006
uh we're just getting started to grow it
start to build in it's quite hard to
grow a company when it's just you um
uh on your own you know knows your your
company name and so on
so 2008 i started to grow it properly
that's when the
financial crisis here so to have this
whole steady uh 2010 i want to start
growing it but there's no one with two
years of recruitment experience
because everyone was either pre-2008
because no one was hiring recruiters in
2008 2009.
so we thought we need to grow this we
can't afford to hire people at this
point
who've got five years four or five years
experience
um so we did our own grad schemes we had
three of them over three years and we
hired two people
uh in 2010 2011 2012.
and we put a lot of resource into that
150 applicants each time chiseled it
down presentations really went to town
to get the right people for those roles
um and three of those six are still with
us today
um new consultant senior consultant he's
now director he's now managing partner
so it's making those key hires that we
at the time was a lot of investment of
time and training
uh from scratch and you just watched
these people grow now it's amazing see
how they've grown on this journey over
the last nine ten years
so having a core crew of people who
would bought in board and trained up
the way we do things um really did help
and then after around that you start
once you've got a reputation and people
know you're good at what you do then
people start coming to you
and you can be a bit more selective but
it's quite hard at the start when you're
just starting out to try and
you know get people from
well-established competitors think why
would i leave here to go to you guys
um fortunately we're not not in that
position now but it's that's how we did
it we scaled it growing through grad
schemes and getting really good people
at the grassroots and training them up
so i've got a couple of sort of quick
five questions to end this but before i
do
justin let me just ask you like you
you've you've been in this game for a
while now
right okay are you implying i'm old
learned a lot so like what
if you were to go back and start this
journey again being a recruitment
entrepreneur run your own recruitment
business what would you do differently
you know i don't that i can't look back
and say i would i
would do anything differently because my
journey would be
i wouldn't understand the journey i i i
i'd have taken i think
i think it's been it's been a it's been
an absolute blast actually
i've loved it and i've and i looking
back on it there's been parts of it
which have been brilliant you know
opening up a business in dubai
and and growing that for the first five
years was so much fun
um and then i had a two or three years
of hurt from various things that
happened outside of my control
from financial you know crisis to oil
price crashes to
growing businesses you know in countries
i'd never really lived in before
but i you know through all that failure
i learned
how to be successful again and actually
uh my
my patch um should we call it that my my
dubai hong kong singapore patch
even in this year of covid because of
what i learned from those failures has
actually had a really good year we've
done the same as we did last year
so it's it's shown me that actually i i
learned from things that happened before
and i wouldn't want to change my journey
because
perhaps i wouldn't have coped so well in
something like this in a pandemic
okay okay and what about you would you
do anything
i'm quite an optimist
look for there's always a a positive in
anything if something goes wrong
well there's a positive there somewhere
if you look for it so i wish
i'd be stretched to find something that
i'd actually say was actually quite bad
um i don't know i suppose we could have
done this model that we're doing a bit
sooner uh potentially
it's great it really really works but uh
like
like justin you have you have things
like we had a time
you know three four years ago were
growing we had
great people were going on trip work
company trips uh
dubai and paris and you know it was a
really really fun time of growth and
you know we're just sort of firing all
cylinders um
then i'll seek over there and we have to
retract a little bit remodel reposition
and now we're back and we're
actually growing at a rate of knots now
so this is trigger
yeah i think there's the challenges
actually make us who we are and
if we hadn't it means you haven't had
those challenges we wouldn't be where we
are now
i love that there is one thing i would
add though that i definitely could have
done better and
and and there is some good people that
slip through our fingers
that i wish were still with us and my
hiring my
my interview process at the beginning of
setting up a recruitment business and
even
until quite recently wasn't the most
thorough it was very much
a gut feel which you know i can't
believe you don't mind i did recruiting
for a business and and
let rely on that for so long um so i
think i'd have been a bit more thorough
in my interview process and worked on my
attrition
a bit harder and uh the other thing is
we weren't so great in our database at
the beginning
and i really regret that because those
bad habits
lasted for some time so you know get you
get a good a database system together
and as a leader
be someone that uses it a lot and it can
show others how to do it because
i wasn't necessarily the best and that
might be because i wasn't you know the
most experienced recruiter when i set up
interesting so i've got a couple of
questions for you guys
to finish this all right so uh first
question i'll come to you down first and
then just a new answer and then we'll do
vice versa
so first question is um dan if you could
change the industry
recruitment industry what would you
improve
um i'd probably like to elevate its
status a bit more
where i don't want recruiters to be
guarded as these pesky people
um you know ultimately we add a lot of
value and the relationships we have
so um i suppose it would be
putting it more in the realms of what
like a lawyer would be or
you know raising the profile that we are
consultants we've got a lot of
experience
like our lady uh kate for example she
works for the count directors she's
been with us for seven years account
manager account director senior account
directors
she's met over five thousands maybe six
thousand account directors now
that value that worth that she has from
that network of interviewing
four or five people a week over the last
seven years that has an inherent worth
and a value and it's the consultancy
that relationship she has
and she might say hello i'm absolutely a
great accountant right that they know
we're fine thanks
but she's saying that i've met seven
thousand account directors this person
is very very good for your role
so it's i suppose it was raising the
whole recruitment
business up a bit so that it's actually
regarded as
being more of a consultancy um than
perhaps a reputation that it has
justin what did you improve yeah i look
i think the
the reputation thing is the journey
we're all on right you know that's why
you're partly why you're doing this
podcast we all want to bring best
practice into the industry
so i'm i just can't stand i couldn't get
it coming
it's a bit i still can't stand now in
recruitment is this transactional
element it's like
people just sling you know clients going
ah send it out to tempe give a job to 10
people let's see what i get back
you know i can't just understand that so
if there's something i would change it
would be to to
to bring the professionalism in to
actually make people like if
people are going to call themselves
consultants like that actually means
something you've got to be consultative
you've got to be able to
talk to a candidate about the journey
they're going on going on
talk to the client about the industry
the best people in the market the
shakers and movers who
they are you've got you've got to
actually consult use that damn word
right
and i think i had i had someone say this
analogy that you wouldn't you know you
wouldn't give your
expense receipt to 10 different
accountants and pay the first person
that sends you the send you the um
the tax receipt back just didn't do that
right so why do we
get in recruitment and that's the bit i
want to try and eradicate is get that
you know raise the reputation and bring
in the consultative element
yeah i love that explains what i'm
saying like people wouldn't go and buy
like a gucci bag and go
three and a half grand i'll give you a
grand for it he's like you just don't
you don't you don't haggle on things
like that i mean you wouldn't go to a
doctor and go well can you do it for
half price so i'm gonna go to the
cheapest doctor or the cheapest lawyer
because they're cheap um so it's raising
that status
um i think on the same page yeah yeah
yeah
so um justin let me come to you this
question then first
what book have you read that has had the
biggest impact on you
oh man you put me on the spot here books
my my um
uh my book collection is not it's not
something that i'm very proud of
it's uh wow i think actually
listen to watched or it could die
right because i i i've really got into
one thing that the
um pandemics got me into is like audio
books and actually listening to
that yeah i wasn't a massive listener to
any podcast until i
till essentially this year happened and
i started listening to
different business people talking about
their success with failures their
vulnerability
and i've really enjoyed listening to
people like martin sorrell i think he's
got a hell of a story
um yeah the recruitment stuff like james
khan
autobiography stuff i find really
interesting i i'm not so much a good
fiction reader
so james khan um his you know his book i
thought was you particularly if you want
to get into recruitment you've got to
read that right
um greg savage he's pretty interesting
he's got quite a lot to say for himself
so the bit i've i've really enjoyed is
listening to entrepreneurs set up and
build their businesses and
listen to people talk about their
success and failure i like it
danny you reader are you a listener what
i use
when i commuted into london i had quite
a long commute i just i got a kindle i
just chewed through books like
i know two a week or something i'm jesus
load of books
and then when i stopped i moved into
london again and into north london i i
just died about i haven't used it it's
ridiculous um
when i'm when i'm walking into town um
i'd say actually i'm more really
like butterfly between all the different
sort of media outlets like the economist
and things like that
i find them fascinating um i think like
most people attention span is quite
short now so
it's jumping on an article reading that
linkedin insights articles the economist
uh me and joshua from sharing articles
and things that we've seen even last
night at
i know 11 p.m my time midday for you you
were we were sharing articles weren't we
around this latest acquisition with
slack and
uh you know um yeah so i suppose me it's
more like
business stuff uh and uh relevant
industry stuff that i found like bite
size that i can
i can chew through and learn from
these podcasts mate i i've picked up two
coaches and a personal branding expert
from listening to you being one of them
so
it serves me pretty well i've got two
more questions for you guys then we'll
we'll end this so dan back to you
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
oh crikey
[ __ ] this is this has been bad when i
first started then
um i think i bought a vespa yeah
yeah i was living in putney now living
in fulham and working in hammersmith and
it was like
it was a 30 minute walk or a five minute
vespa scooter
or six minutes if i hit the lights so i
bought a vesper and it was it was two
and a half grand it was another
green uh what's it called like a racing
green brown leather
uh yeah i nearly died several times um
nipping from pullum to hammersmith
around that bus station
uh but yeah i bought that and it saved
me quite it saved me an hour a day and
it was actually really fun
love that justin you're not as glamorous
as that
uh my mind paying off a credit card and
going on going to ibiza and getting in
more debt again
so final question guys and that is
justin
first to you what what is the ultimate
goal for your
recruitment career
me yeah yeah look i think it's
it's to continue to build on this
credibility aspect i think we've we've
really
i think if you look at our business now
we've got 10 offices we've got like 60
people
we've got a really nice name for
ourselves so if we can we've got
brilliant platform to grow from and
we've managed to survive
and thrive in a pandemic year so if we
can do it now i think the next 10 years
is going to be dead exciting and
it's you know it's to build something i
i'm not of this mindset of building
something to sell
i want to build something to enjoy and
have a series of mini retirements whilst
doing it
there you go love that dan i mean i was
working out
we placed literally thousands of people
over the years
um and that's also something we're quite
proud of doing but right now i'm really
proud of that we're
able to i'm looking forward to launching
like 100 businesses
because these 100 people have their own
businesses that they can then develop
and grow and then ultimately sell
and go on to need another life or do
what they want to do further down the
line so
um i think for me it's being able to uh
organize this and manage in a way that
people are able to develop and grow
their businesses um successfully um
you know we're not here to take over the
world like you know
amazon or walmart but we are here to
scale it in the right right ways and get
the right people and give them the
opportunity to
to succeed and ultimately those people
go on to help other people to
love succe guys it's been an absolute
pleasure